All right, well, you
know, I love the holidays.
You know that about me.
I love the holidays.
And a big part of Christmas, folks,
is well, spending time
with your loved ones.
For me, that's Andy Richter
here, sitting next to me.
Aw, come on.
(studio audience applauds)
It is.
Golly.
You know, Andy and I have
become very good friends
in the three seasons that
we've been doing this show.
[Andy] Right.
And we decided, actually recently,
that I should get to
know Andy even better.
And Andy should take me to Chicago
and look around his old neighborhood.
Andy Richter Chicago.
[Andy] Right.
Sort of some of your old haunts.
Yeah.
Well, we did that last night on the show,
we took a camera crew.
Yeah.
We went to Chicago.
You showed me around.
I think we visited 85 bars,
and we had a good time.
[Andy] Yes.
We really did.
[Andy] As far as we know.
That's right.
Well, tonight,
tonight is part two
of the installment.
Well, this where we went,
I was wondering who was living
in my old apartment now.
You know,
and most people couldn't
just go ring on the bell,
but when you bring a camera crew.
You can get away with stuff, right.
You can.
So Andy and I went to
where you used to live,
and this really happened.
We just rang the bell and
things unfolded, as they say.
Let's take a look now at
our visit to Andy's old pad
in Chicago.
Take a look.
All right, Conan, this is
the apartment I lived at.
Oh, it's nice, it's really nice.
Yeah, I have no idea who lives there now.
This is sort of, Lincoln
had his log cabin,
and you started out in
this humble apartment.
Right here on Cullom Street in Chicago.
All right.
So I thought we'd just ring the buzzer
and see who's there.
Do you know, you don't
know these people at all?
No, I have no idea.
All right, let's just ring
it and see what happens.
Okay.
(buzzer buzzes)
I hope they're home.
Yeah.
(intercom clicks)
[Julie] Who is it?
Hi, it's Andy Richter and Conan O'Brien
from "Late Night with Conan O'Brien."
I used to live here and we're wondering
if we could come up with a video tape crew
and film the apartment.
[Julie] I'm sorry, right
now wouldn't be a good time.
Now?
How come?
[Julie] I have guests.
Um, could I talk to her?
[Andy] Yeah.
[Conan] Ma'am, Ma'am?
I don't think you understand.
This is Conan O'Brien talking now,
that was Andy Richter.
(studio audience laughs)
It would really be great.
We came all the way from New York City
and it'll just take a second.
We'll just, you know, see
where Andy used to live.
And it'll just take a
second, I promise you.
(silence)
Well, I think I've pretty
much got her on the ropes.
I think she's about to give in.
Yeah, hello?
Hello?
[Andy] I bet they're coming
to the window to look at us.
[Conan] You think?
Hello?
Now wouldn't be a good time.
[Andy] When can we come?
(studio audience titters)
[Conan] Are they turning lights out?
[Julie] Back up from the door.
[Andy] What?
[Conan] What?
[Julie] Back up from the door.
[Conan] Back up from the door, okay.
[Andy] See, it's really us.
It's us.
Can you see us?
Back up more.
Hello?
Are you peeking through the blinds?
(studio audience laughs)
We're on after Leno.
(studio audience laughs and applauds)
It's "Must See TV."
Hello?
Can you see us?
We're really are who we say we are.
(studio audience laughs)
Yeah, we're not just
celebrity impersonators.
Although boy, what a sad
celebrity impersonating pair
that would be!
[Andy] You'll be on national television.
[Conan] Yeah, there might
even be some money in it.
(studio audience laughs)
[Julie] Come on in.
All right.
Oh, cool.
(studio laughs and applauds)
See that, they're on
national television got them.
I think I mentioned money.
[Andy] Oh, you did?
Yeah.
Hi there!
Hi, I'm Andy.
Hi Andy!
Hi, nice to meet you.
Your name is? - I'm Julie.
Hi Julie. - Hi.
Couldn't you have called
first or something?
[Conan] It's better this way.
[Andy] That's the whole point.
[Conan] This is the way
Ed McMahon does it on TV.
(studio audience titters)
I didn't win a million
dollars or anything?
[Conan] No, no.
This is, the only difference
is he gives a million dollars
and there might be a 20 in it for you,
or something with us.
You're probably just
gonna criticize, like,
the bathroom's not clean
and stuff like that.
[Andy] No, not at all.
[Conan] Cool idea, let's go.
[Andy] Can we come in?
They've done the bathroom really nice.
It was a dump before.
[Conan] This is nice.
Yeah.
Look at this.
This actually worked out really well.
Look, it's their little toilet elf.
(Conan and studio audience laugh)
[Conan] It's always
there when you need him.
(studio audience laughs and applauds)
Actually, I kicked through this door once.
Not this door, but it was another door,
and I kicked through it.
We're just getting these weird flashes
of what your life was once like.
This room is littered with empties,
ladies and gentlemen.
It's Chicago.
(Conan laughs)
I guess that's just --
It's the holidays.
Yeah, look, what's going on here?
It's just, there's something.
You have a problem,
you realize that, don't you?
Yep.
We're here to help you.
Bottles are all over the place
and none in the refrigerator.
Here. (Conan laughs)
Look at this!
(studio audience laughs)
This is the kind of
thing you get awards for,
in Chicago.
(Conan and studio audience laugh)
(studio audience applauds)
[Conan] Is there a picture
here, anywhere, of your fiance?
Yeah, there's one right here.
[Conan] Could we see a
picture of him, please?
Mm hmm.
[Andy] Oh, he's a very handsome man.
[Conan] He's a handsome guy.
You make a very handsome couple.
[Julie] Well, thank you.
Oh, I am having people coming over,
so that's why the place is at least
in somewhat decent order.
Wow, and what a
conversation piece that is.
[Conan] Oh!
Oh, Andy.
Oh, my God!
[Conan] Andy, no!
Tell me it's not broken.
[Conan] Andy, it's fine.
[Andy] Oh!
Everything's fine, ladies and gentlemen.
[Andy] Look, it's still
intact, just like their love.
(studio audience cheers and applauds)
Hey, you knew --
look, she knew we were coming
Oh!
And she baked, I think those are quiches,
if I'm not mistaken.
No, that's a Chicago
delicacy called Baco Pie.
Made with Bacos.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Is that a Baco Pie, ma'am?
[Julie] No, it's sun dried tomato quiche.
Wow, excellent.
(studio audience titters)
I know what I'm talking about.
Very nice.
Thank you for those, I appreciate it.
We'll take those on the way out.
Was there a piano here,
when you were here, Andy?
No, no piano.
You, you play the piano, is that right?
[Julie] I play a little bit.
[Conan] Can you play
us a little something?
Okay, are we ready?
Let's go.
I believe we're ready.
[Conan] Okay.
(Julie plays three
chords of "Jingle Bells")
Come on, you're supposed to sing.
No, no, that's just the introduction.
No, it's not.
Jingle bells.
Okay, wow, here we go.
Okay. Wow.
Okay.
♪ Jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
Why aren't you singing?
Because I'm playing.
♪ Oh what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ On a one horse open sleigh ♪
In a one horse --
♪ Sleigh, hey ♪
♪ Hey, back off, man. ♪
(studio audience laughs, cheers, applauds)
Hey, you guys think you
wanna play some board games?
I think we're all right.
Yeah, I'm all right.
Yeah, we're okay.
All right.
(studio audience laughs)
(chatter from TV show)
Beer?
(studio audience laughs)
(door knocks)
Hi.
Hey, hi, how are you, Christian?
Jesus, what's up?
Hi, how are you?
Not much, this is Andy.
Hi, Christian.
Hey, you're here.
I heard a lot about you.
Julie, thanks again.
Hi, nice to see you again.
How are you?
Listen, basically,
well, Andy explained,
we were here last night
and you were very nice
to have us and let us in.
Thank you.
Yeah, basically,
so we thought --
Since you were so nice
that we would come back
with a surprise for you.
A big surprise.
And, so that's what we
want to do right now.
So here it is,
Here he is.
Oh, hey, how you doing?
[Conan] Jerry Springer.
(studio audience cheers and applauds)
♪ Jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ On a one horse open sleigh, hey ♪
We thought it might be nice,
Jerry, since you're here,
if you could end things
with a final thought.
(studio audience titters)
(audience member hoots)
Well, I guess I want to say that,
for those of us in Chicago,
there are fewer things
that we're more proud of
than to see Andy make it so
big in the world of television,
in the world of entertainment.
And to see you come back to your roots,
it kinda makes us all feel
a little bit, you know,
we well up in our eyes
thinking of you, Andy.
What you've done, and--
(studio audience laughs
and applauds lightly)
You all right?
Yeah.
But America should know
that with Andy and Conan
here in Chicago on this night,
New York has never been safer.
(studio audience laughs and applauds)
That's a really nice
thought, thank you very much.
Tell them to stay in school.
Kids, Andy said it best
when he said stay in school.
(studio audience cheers
and applauds lightly)
(tortilla chips crunch)
(studio audience cheers and applauds)
It was nice to go back.
Wow.
Merry Christmas, Andy.
Merry Christmas.
All right, folks.
We're gonna take a quick break.
I think we learned a lot there.
Our thanks to Chicago, and
of course, Jerry Springer.
When we come back, Kevin
Pollak's gonna be with us,
so stick around.